conseil municipal extraordinaire ce
matin à magny les hameaux cette classe
de collégiens s'essaie à l'exercice non
sans difficulté
comment fonctionne une mairie comment
sont élus le maire et ses adjoints c'est
ce que ses enfants lui tenter de
comprendre mais après dans un conseil
municipal
comment on élus les
adjoints au maire
j'ai appris aussi commander lui le maire
comment ça se passe les débats etc c'est
à cet âge là que sa rentrée ils ont
besoin d'entendre ces valeurs il
découvre plein de choses aussi parce que
par exemple l'élection du maire il
pensait que c'était les habitants
donc là ça permet de leur dire qu'en
fait non c'est le conseil municipal au
même moment dehors leurs camarades ont
le droit à un cours d'histoire ou plutôt
un cours du blé noir on est où là oh oui
non non
c'est presque ça ça s'appelle
le carré de mémoire ces anciens
combattants de la guerre d'algérie
partagent leurs souvenirs plus ou moins
douloureux dans l'espoir de rappeler à
ces jeunes esprits qu'il ne faut pas
oublier le passé et que la guerre est
toujours évitable une des façons
perpétré la mémoire c'est de raconter ce
qui s'est passé afin que ce ne soit pas
oublié
c'est de leur faire comprendre que la
guerre c'est pas la solution dans une
actualité entachée par le terrorisme et
d'autres crises ces leçons de civisme et
de vivre ensemble ont plus que jamais
leur place